Alex Byrne the state librarian and the law to to have you here on this beautiful day.
Welcome to this most important and timely symposium on the eight hundredth anniversary of the Magna Carta.
I start by acknowledging the traditional owners of the land on which we come together they get a go of the nation pay
my respects to their elders past and present and to indigenous people here today.
I acknowledge shared freedoms and responsibilities in heritage from Magna Carta through the common law.
Very apt things to say today and I also acknowledge that welcoming of the peoples and cultures of the world.
All three elements shaping a stray. Pleased to welcome our speakers. NICHOLAS COWDERY Q.C.
Professor David Clark Professor John Hirst Dr Rosemary Lang and Andrew.
President as a library Council of New South Wales and a master of ceremonies Emeritus Professor David Camm
and I am president of the history Council of New South Wales and all of our distinguished guests.
I'm sure that you will thank me.
Sorry you wanting me you'll join me in thanking our organizers and especially Dr Mandy Krishna.
Executive Officer of the history Council of New South Wales.
They've done a marvelous job in bringing this meeting together.
A library is an amazing place amazing buildings and so much to offer with over six million items in our collection.
It's a vibrant treasure house of knowledge as puts it this library holds the D.N.A.
Of a strategy of the greatest collection on at country and it's region peoples and our cultures.
And of course we hold an early copy of Magna Carta which is. On display today just to my left and in the Bronx.
You can look at it and my colleague Maggie Patton will tell you a little bit about its history.
It's one of the many irreplaceable our times in our collection.
It dates from the early fourteenth century it was included in a compilation of the statutes of England.
Evidently travelling advocate.
The idea hundredth anniversary of the ceiling of Magna Carta in a few weeks on the fifteenth of June provides the
appropriate opportunity to read examine this document and its role in British
and Australian history that ceiling marked an important step in the movement away from the tree monarchical road
towards responsible constitutional government speech seen as a foundation document for the rights of citizens including
the essential rights to freedom of expression
and freedom of access to information rights which are fundamental to libraries and to this great library.
We stand for the right of all to express their views peacefully and respecting the rights of others
and for those views to be recorded in our collections.
The heart
and security of same here today as being necessary to safeguard that right of free expression to protect this valuable
document and to protect library Raiders and visitors. Many say to limit the rights expressed in Magna Carta.
And develop three successive centuries.
You know other key documents on human rights and of course incorporated into our legal system. All of a Cromwell.
The Lord Protector of England famously use scatological rhyming slang to dismiss Magna Carta.
And similarly you scuttle logically abuse the lighter petition of rod. I'm not allowed to use his words here.
Many have followed him in denying seeking to limit human rights instruments whether from.
Well lack of respect for others all seek to deny the rights of others this great institution straight his oldest
library stands for freedom of expression and freedom of access to information in common. Without the libraries.
We're open to all and our collection encompasses all views.
We're proud to work with the history Council of New South Wales to host this important symposium.
It's now my pleasant duty to introduce him so you for today.
Emeritus Professor David Cameron
and I go back a long way since we both worked at the Northern Territory University now Charles Darwin University my
colleagues for many years. It's a great pleasure to welcome David. To the podium. Thank you.
Thank you thank you Dr Alex Bernd for that wonderful introduction I would also like to welcome you here on behalf of
the history Council yourself whiles.
And as Alex did I would acknowledge the traditional owners of the land where we currently placed the chemical PEOPLE OF
THE NATION.
I always believe that it's particularly appropriate to do that on an occasion when we are discussing history.
My remarks now will be brief.
The history Council was delighted to be approached by the Magna Carta Committee
and the role of the institute to be involved in this event and I'm so pleased that it has attracted a good response.
The event has been fully booked and I think that indicates that there is a real thirst for knowledge
and understanding of the Magna Carta in this very important year
when we commemorate what happened so many hundreds of years ago. I remarked to Nick Cowdery as we were.
Waiting outside that like many historians. I don't know nearly as much about the Magna Carta as I ought to.
My history is quite good for the ancient period and quite good from about the seventeen.
Hundreds on boards but there is a regrettable gap that I'm just in recent years it's been trying to fill in.
So I'm hoping to learn a great deal today and I'm sure the time Will.
I'd like to take this opportunity of thanking the Magna Carta Committee
and the Rule of Law Institute for their initiative with this event it was a pleasure to work with them.
I'd also like to. Pipe to Cuba.
A tribute to my predecessor as president of the history Council Emeritus Professor Richard Waterhouse he did much of
the initial work in getting this event together
and I don't think it would have happened without his efforts as well I'd like to acknowledge the hard work particularly
over the last month or so of my Dr Mann to critique the executive officer of the history Council
and the administrative assistants. Stephanie Holland's. They have helped to.
Again make this event practical practical and possible
and they have been all sorts of last minute details to which the I have to attend finally
and I'll thank them again at the end did I
but I'd like to express my gratitude to the speakers we've got a very eminent group of speakers people who come to us
with.
A great deal of expertise people who are also very busy so it's great to have them they are
and I think that as the day goes on we'll appreciate their presence any more on just a couple of practical housekeeping
announcements the event is being filmed.
DI and as is often the case this kind of occasion I would ask everyone to make sure that they my pal phones are off.
Throughout the day and I've been guilty myself speaking at an occasion like this of having my phone go off.
It's very embarrassing
and it's also a problem if it's off in the audience so if you could do that I'd be nice to grateful
or without further ado I'd like to to now introduce Professor Nick Cowdery from the Magna Carta Committee. Thank you.
Good morning ladies and gentlemen my task.
Just at the moment is to welcome you all here on behalf of the Magna Carta Committee of the role of the Institute of
Australia. A sponsor of this event with the history society.
The Rule of Law Institute is a very active group of people who engage in a number of different kinds of activity
directed towards the promotion of the rule of law
and the protection of the rule of law as a fundamental principle of government and governance in our community
and of course it connects very directly with the Magna Carta
and with the principles that have been derived from that instrument
and I'll be saying much more about that in a few minutes rather more Institute activities include a great deal of
outreach to the community.
And particularly to schools
and we have education officers who travel to schools in New South Wales in Queensland in Victoria South Australia so
far. Maybe the rest of the country in times to come. Carrying the message of the role of war but also for this year.
Of course the message of the Magna Carta. And we have had some wonderful events staged by. Our education. Officers.
Nick Clark has here in the corner down there and Jackie who assists him
and others who are brought in from time to time to assist and it's obviously very important.
That high school students understand the foundational principles of our society as they learn history as they learn
systems of government.
And complete their education so on behalf of the Rule of Law Institute in particular the Magna Carta Committee.
Welcome. Very pleased to be part of this event and we hope that you will find it a stimulating day and.
To an extent reinforcement of many of those principles that we hold dear. Thank you.